I'm Glen bth I'm a professor of Robotics
and machine learning at the University
of Montreal and a core member of Mila a
while ago as I was a kid I was always
really interested in basically taking
apart Electronics just really wanted to
understand how they worked one of the
things I really like about working at
Mila is like the large diversity of
different machine learning people I can
work with in my research they have a lot
of passion a lot of interest in solving
a lot of the problems that we are you
know facing these days we're all trying
to learn about the most interesting
problems that are related to our
research trying to share this
information the best that we can amongst
each
other the students in the lab get this
extra ability to have access to these
really interesting hardware tools we've
got a lot of compute servers and things
that mea that we can train objects but
there really is nothing quite like
seeing if you can cause like a physical
change in the world with the algorithms
that you
create one of the real advantages that
machine learning is giving robotics
these days is the ability for the
methods to be more flexible one of the
Futures that we can hope to create by
having more adaptable robotic systems is
also a more adaptable Society if you
know we can make a robotic system that
can end up doing a lot of different
types of cooking it'd be really exciting
in this case because we can now you know
grow our ability to be able to produce
food for people across Society we really
need to push the boundaries of what we
can do with machine learning and deep
learning methods such that we can really
kind of reach that level of having like
adaptive systems that can really be
assistance for
us